man see baby slip 5 billion under the
tree for me Nancy I've been an awfully
good boy
Nancy baby or we're gonna shut down the
government tonight and we absolutely
should we will analyze the stakes of the
impending government Christmas shutdown
then speaking of shutdowns
the Trump foundation dissolves amid
accusations of improperly spending funds
an 11 year old boy dances in drag for
dollar bills at a gay bar in Brooklyn
what else is new
a woman almost becomes Miss Universe I'm
sorry a man almost becomes Miss Universe
I know that's confusing and the New York
Times calls for the extinction of the
human race
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
talk about a confusing day of news we've
got so much to get to in the week before
Christmas but first let's make a little
money honey with mint mobile there is
nothing better about the holiday season
than unwrapping a brand new phone until
you get hit with a brand new monthly
phone bill you didn't see that one
coming big wireless providers can really
suck the joy out of the holiday season
so this year
don't just upgrade your phone upgrade
your wireless provider and switch to
mint mobile for a limited time mint
Mobile is offering the best holiday deal
and Wireless you've ever seen three
months of service for only $20 this is a
limited time offer three months for $20
that is a significantly less than you're
paying now I bet it's only here for a
limited time twenty bucks three months
of wireless service with five gigabytes
of 4G LTE data each month plus unlimited
talks to talk and text use your own
phone with any mint mobile plan you can
give your old phone number along with
all your existing contacts mint mobile
runs on the nation's fastest most
advanced LTE network of you nine hundred
percent satisfied but you will be mint
mobile has you covered with seven day
money-back guarantee ditch the old
wireless bill start saving with mint
mode we'll get three months of wireless
for 20 bucks get the holiday deal before
it's gone get the plan shipped to your
door for free by going to mint mobile
comm slash qoph fa ce o-- VF e EF e
that's mint mobile comm slash cough fa c
OV e fe fe three months of service for
just 20 bucks at you guessed it mint
mobile comm slash cough fa all i want
for christmas is 5 billion dollars and a
wall is that so much to ask is that so
much to ask for Christmas is right
around the corner I've been an awfully
good boy Santa baby we're looking at a
very real possibility of a government
shutdown this is interesting timing for
a shutdown because everyone is tuned out
of the news Christmas is around the
corner New Year's is around the corner
people aren't doing work half of our
staff is probably on a beach in Boca
right now and so the you know this
timing isn't the best time to draw
attention to the stakes of a shutdown
but it might be the best time to shut it
down because people won't really care
you won't catch a lot of political flack
and president Trump might be able to get
his wall that's what this is all about
there have
two distinct responses from the White
House about this as always you know the
White House is sending different people
on out on TV and they they have very
different tactics on the shutdown you
remember President Trump was arguing
with Chuck and Nancy on the best reality
television show in the world and he said
to Chuck Schumer I'll own it I'll take
responsibility for the shutdown I will
shut down the government to protect our
border and Democrats were thrilled
because they got Trump to say that he
was gonna shut down the government the
question is do you take responsibility
for it or do you try to say that it's
really the Democrats fault and really
the Democrats are shutting down the
government Stephen Miller clearly favors
the former approach here he is on Face
the Nation to this question the border
wall which I know you're huge advocate
for we are about five days from
potential government shutdown and
Republican leadership says there's no
plan what is the president's plan and
will he shut it down to get this five
billion in border wall funding we're
gonna do whatever is necessary to build
the border wall to stop this ongoing
crisis of illegal immigration and that
means this is a this is a very if it
comes to it absolutely this is a very
fundamental issue at stake is the
question of whether or not the United
States remains a sovereign country
whether or not we can establish and
enforce rules for entrance into our
country the Democrat Party is a simple
choice they can either choose to fight
for America's working class or to
promote illegal immigration you can't do
both is there totally comes out swinging
this guy one of the best people in the
administration and he's coming out and
saying yep we'll shut it down we own it
that's what's going to happen because we
want to protect the border now here is
White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders giving the opposite approach the
president wants five billion would he
take two and a half billion would that
be an acceptable number we would take we
have other ways that we can get to that
five billion that we will work with
Congress if they will make sure that we
get a bill passed that provides not just
the funding for the wall but there's a
piece of legislation that's been pushed
around that Democrats actually voted 26
to 5 out of committee that provides 26
roughly twenty six billion dollars in
border security including 1.6 billion
dollars
the wall that's something that we would
be able to support as long as we can
couple that with other funding resources
that is he so you see there when Stephen
Miller is on the show he says I'm not
going to negotiate I'm not going to try
to figure out this negotiation on live
television and we're gonna get the money
or we're shutting down the government
Sarah Sanders goes on TV and says well
you know there there are other ways to
get the money for the wall and well
maybe we don't need to shut down the
government well I'm not so sure we'll
see what happens and then Kelly and
Conway a senior adviser of the president
gives the clearest version of this which
is she says we do not want to shut down
the government on Lou Dobbs maker in the
Oval Office Lou I believe that there is
a much better chance of getting a deal
than not but look the president wants to
keep the government open he just doesn't
want the borders to remain open the way
they are he wants there to be full
funding for the government but that
funding must include adequate funding
for border security I don't know if he
can be any more clear on this issue and
I don't know if we could see any more
excerpts from Democrats in the past who
voted for secure fences act in 2006
including Hillary Clinton Barack Obama
Joe Biden Chuck Schumer and the whole
lot of them and then of course you've
seen all the video clips of them
supporting borders and security before
so they need to come up and do it and
vote the president doesn't want to shut
down the government he couldn't be more
clear now of course the President did
say I will own the government shutdown I
will shut down the government he said it
in the Oval Office Stephen Miller said
just about the same thing but what Sarah
Sanders and Kelly and Conway are doing
is taking the much more traditional
approach which has been the
long-standing conventional wisdom which
is you don't want to bear responsibility
for a government shutdown voters will
punish you for that it won't do you well
at the ballot box in the next elections
what President Trump and Stephen Miller
are doing is taking the new trumpian
more assertive more masculine approach
which is yup you're darn tootin that
we're gonna shut down the government and
we're gonna do it for a good reason and
you should be thrilled that we're going
to do it that approach I think that is
the right approach I think the
conventional wisdom is wrong
I think people especially in this
political moment do
want to hear mealy-mouthed people don't
want to hear about how we want to have
conciliation with democrats who are
advocating for open borders we want we
really want to keep the government open
shut it down who cares
most of the government is already funded
people are forgetting this isn't a total
government shutdown most of the
government is funded there are a few
departments of Department of Homeland
Security Justice I think State
Department still need some funding so
those areas may have a partial shutdown
okay fine
who cares so what essential employees
will remain on on the dole they will
remain on the job they will keep working
and non-essential employees won't be
working for now they'll ultimately be
back paid and we can make a point to get
the wall I mean this is a big winning
issue the the reason I favor this Trump
and Stephen Miller approach one is I
don't think voters actually punish
politicians for shutting down the
government I there we had a big
government shutdown in 2013 and then
Republicans took the Senate in 2014 they
blame the Republicans in 2013 a year
later they win the Senate i I don't see
evidence of that throughout recent
history but this is the approach that
Ronald Reagan took there was a famous
moment during the Reagan presidency
where the air traffic controllers
federal workers decided that they were
gonna go on strike and this was illegal
it was illegal for these guys to go on
strike it disrupted the nation's Airways
had disrupted a lot of travel and their
federal employees they're not allowed to
do that they went on strike
anyway after long time negotiating with
the government everyone thought Reagan
was gonna cave well you know Nancy we
want to keep everybody on the job but
well well you know he didn't do that at
all
Ronald Reagan stood firm he gave exactly
the same approach to great effect it is
for this reason that I must tell those
who failed to report for duty that this
morning they are in violation of the law
and if they do not report for work
within 48 hours they have forfeited
their jobs and will be terminated
that's correct
what lesser action can there be the law
is very explicit
they have violating the law and as I say
we call this to the attention of their
leadership whether this was conveyed to
the membership before they voted to
strike I don't know but this is one of
the reasons why there could be no
further negotiation while this situation
continues classic Reagan and this is
where that great acting training that
Reagan had came into play where the
reporter says isn't there some lesser
action you can undertake what lesser
action can there be they violated the
law and is he was absolutely right
they're violating the law they forfeit
their jobs they will be terminated that
was the right approach it broke that
Union as it should have it certainly
should have broken the federal union he
stood for him and he won this is a
winning issue for Republicans CBS poll
shows 51 percent of Americans the
majority of Americans want a border wall
think about that they mocked us for
years about the border wall on the left
the majority of Americans according to
CBS wanted 54 percent according to a
Harris Poll a Harvard bowl rather want
an electronic and a physical structure
which is to say a wall there was this
terrible story over the weekend of this
seven-year-old Guatemalan girl
seven-year-old Guatemalan girl crossing
the border illegally with her father
she's apprehended she dies in custody
and immediately the left blamed border
patrol for this blamed Republicans
there's of course no evidence for that
this poor girl's name was Jacqueline
called machiene she and her father were
arrested she started vomiting pretty
quickly she was immediately airlifted by
the United States government to a
hospital in El Paso Texas
she had a hundred and 5.9 degree
temperature when she got to the station
the agents revived the child twice they
initially thought
dehydration now it looks like it was
sepsis that did it the girl's father
said the border agents did everything
that they could it's not that he didn't
feed her for days it's that she couldn't
eat food she couldn't drink she couldn't
eat food they did everything they could
to revive her but she died anyway what
did she die from she died from illegal
immigration that's what she did this is
the cause of the this is the effect of
illegal immigration as this seven year
old girl dies this is the effect of
creating an incentive structure that
gets people who are
desperate to cross the border illegally
put their whole families at great risk
and die despite all the best medical
care in the world immediate medical care
provided by the federal government we
know the fusion and Amnesty
International studies shows 60 to 80
percent of young women and girls who
cross the border illegally
are sexually assaulted or raped that is
the moral argument against illegal
immigration and it's the people who are
incentivizing this awful system that
have to take responsibility for this
tragedy not the American government we
got a lot more to talk about but first
we've got to make a little bit more
money with Robin Hood Robin Hood is an
investing app that lets you buy and sell
stocks ETFs options and Kryptos all
commissioned free this is a wonderful
sponsor I love these guys it's simple
and intuitive clear design with data
presented in an easy to digest way I
like this I am financially mostly
illiterate and what's great about Robin
Hood is you just you open up the app and
it asks you all of these pertinent
questions about you about what you want
what you're getting who you are what
your age is this that and the other
thing and it will really shape how you
invest in your financial strategy it's
really good nope no Commission fees
other brokerages charge up to 10 bucks
for every trade Robin Hood doesn't
charge commission fees you can trade
stocks and keep all of your profits it
is easy to understand that there are
charts and market data you can place a
trade in just four taps on your
smartphone this is very important you
know like you think of the old time you
guys like buy buy buy sell sell sell you
just go tap tap tap tap tap tap it's a
it's really nice really lets you channel
your old timey stock trader and it's and
you can learn by doing you learn how to
invest as you build your portfolio this
is my favorite part of Robin Hood is it
actually teaches me how to invest just
by by the fact of doing it by leading me
along Robin Hood is giving listeners a
free stock like Apple Ford or sprint to
help build your portfolio
imagine if they've given you that's
Apple stock in the 80s gosh should be a
zillionaire by now
sign up at knowles canada wles dot Robin
Hood com that is Knolls KO w le s dot
Robin Hood dot-com do it now so speaking
of things shutting down the federal
government may shut down the Trump
Foundation has officially shut down this
the left is so excited about this and
it's because they've never looked in a
mirror it's because I think the left
collectively
don't have any mirrors so they're really
thrilled about the president Trump's
charity the Trump foundation shutting
down they don't realize how poorly this
reflects on them it's being shut down
with over a deal with the New York
Attorney General the whole investigation
into the the the Trump foundation is
because of the New York Attorney General
the New York AG found quote a shocking
pattern of illegality and they said that
the Foundation's decision to shut down
was quote an important victory for the
rule of law yes this Democrat New York
Attorney General she got her scalp that
you know if the federal government won't
overturn the 2016 election and take down
Trump the New York corrupt politicians
will and okay fine they're trying to get
Trump what is missing in this story what
they fail to mention is that President
Trump tried to shut down this foundation
two years ago actually the only reason
he didn't shut it down two years ago is
because the AG was dragging it out for
this investigation to try to embarrass
Trump now the AG says yes in 2018 we've
got Trump to shut down his his
foundation no what you did is you got it
to take two years longer than it should
have the reason that they're shutting it
down is that they found that the
foundation used some funds for business
interests and one claim is that they
they illegally or they they misused
funds because the foundation settled
claims against the foundation which is
perfectly reasonable that's perfectly
fine that's not a misuse of funds that's
not legitimate now they're saying they
used Foundation funds to resolve
disputes against a Trump organization
against the business okay maybe they did
maybe they didn't I don't really know
they say that the Trump foundation
promised to donate a lot of money to
veterans but then they only donated a
lot of money to veterans this is
actually a claim you remember in 2016
President Trump there was a dispute over
a debate or a candidate forum and Trump
said he would hold a rally and donate
the money to veterans charities they
said well he didn't donate money to
veterans charities but then also we do
know that in 2016 the Trump Foundation
donated a ton of money millions of
dollars to veterans charities so which
is it
they're trying to have it both ways it's
very unclear clearly the foundation
donated some money to charity was it
used improperly maybe it was maybe it
wasn't the the left has two options here
they can either compare it to the
Clinton Foundation and say see you have
a foundation - you guys are just as bad
as our 2016 presidential candidate oh
you guys are just as bad as the Clintons
the most important family and the
Democratic okay never mind maybe that
doesn't work so well for them the the
other option is to say look how corrupt
President Trump is and and not to draw
any comparisons to the Clinton
Foundation obviously there is a
comparison there are two political
family foundations they that maybe
misused money in some way maybe they
didn't they've had investigations into
them okay there's that comparison but on
substantive matters there's really not
much of a comparison between between the
Trump Foundation and the Clinton
Foundation President Trump when he was
elected decided to dissolve his
foundation the Clintons while Bill
Clinton was president created their
foundation president Trump saw there
might be a conflict of interest here
dissolves this foundation the Clintons
create one specifically at the end of
Bill Clinton's term 1997 I think it was
founded while Hillary is planning a run
for the Senate before she becomes
Secretary of State specifically to
encourage bribes and corruption in her
foundation now why was Trump's
Foundation's money misused it looks like
it was sloppy mismanagement basically
yeah I don't see evidence of some grand
conspiracy here why was the Clintons
money misused because of a specific
deceptive campaign to take money from
foreign governments in exchange for
government favors the entire thing was
set up to solicit bribes obviously the
Trump Foundation wasn't set up to
solicit bribes he wasn't in office for
the vast majority of the the
Foundation's existence and then the main
issue here is there's no comparison in
the media treatment how did the media
cover the Clinton Foundation have they I
don't know have they covered the Clinton
Foundation not very much and this
they're spiking the football they're so
excited this is why we should actually
be happy about this media treatment this
is why mainstream media attacks against
Trump don't work this is why
conservatives are rallying around this
guy this is why Christians conservatives
why we're all defending the payments to
the porn star rightly so defending the
payments to the porn store it's because
of the abject hypocrisy here because it
is so unfair for the media and
apparently the federal government and
the state governments to go after
President Trump for things that they
completely let Democrats off the hook
for you know marks I think quoting
angles said that history repeats itself
first is tragedy then as farce and
that's what we're seeing here that's
what we're seeing playing out in the
Trump foundation we see that the tragedy
of the Clinton administration the
tragedy of Hillary Clinton's awful
career in public service all the damage
she's done to our country and then you
see a play out in the forest of
President Trump and the thing about
forest is we can admit even supporters
of President Trump can admit a lot of
his administration is funny a lot of it
has given us a great joy and laughter
the tweets are funny even a lot of the
policies that overturn so many Democrat
policies are very funny the forest can
be a good thing it is in some ways
borne out of the culture that the
Clinton administration created and this
is just the funny good version of that
the left simply can't take that joke so
moving on from farce moving on from a
happy story we've got to talk about the
most disturbing story in the news maybe
all year I actually don't know that
there's a more disturbing story all year
long there is an 11 year old boy Desmond
Naples who has the worst parents in the
history of the world I don't know maybe
not like the history of the world I mean
there was some parents have like eating
their children before I don't know I
mean that might be it slightly worse
this is pretty bad though on December
1st
an 11 year old boy named Desmond Naples
dressed up in drag went to a gay bar in
Brooklyn called the $3 bill and started
dancing on the bar dressed as Gwen
Stefani while the adult male patrons
threw dollar bills at him and this was
encouraged this was celebrated and the
bar
by the way the the bar in in Brooklyn
the $3 bill doesn't allow any cameras
doesn't allow any cell phones in there
because obviously they're up to some
pretty weird stuff if they're inviting
11 year old drag queens up there and
throwing dollar bills at him I'm not
going to play the video of this
obviously because I assume that's
illegal
I assume it's so bizarre that I don't
want I mean actually frankly given the
current state of social media and
conservative discourse they'd probably
let that video stay up that one would do
just fine on Facebook and Twitter in
YouTube but if I start talking about the
traditional definition of marriage
they'll shut me down say it's hate
speech it's awful should be illegal what
I will play though is the treatment of
this story in the mainstream media
because the treatment by major outlets
like The Today Show is probably just as
disturbing as the video itself Esmond
appleís is smart self-assured talented
he loves to dress up and work the runway
and drag with dramatic makeup but only
if his homework is done that's because
desmond is just 10 years old but he's
already a social media star and he says
he wants to use his platform to inspire
other kids to love and accept themselves
Sunday in the park with ten-year-old
Desmond Annapolis this is one of his
favorite playgrounds all right I'm gonna
cut it before they actually show that
the kid on the drag carpet isn't that so
isn't it so wonderful isn't it's just
it's his favorite playground one of his
favorite playgrounds is the playground
for children where they play and then
the other one is a highly sexualized
runway where old creepy men can leer at
him and throw dollar bills at it isn't
that so nice isn't that so sweet
how wonderful this is the logical
conclusion of of left-wing tolerance
tolerance is not a great thing you know
Bishop Baron was on the Bishop Baron
who's this Catholic bishop and a social
media store was on Ben Shapiro's Sunday
special and he talked about how
tolerance is the virtue of the modern
era but it's not a traditional virtue
it's not a classical virtue it's not a
Christian virtue we should not be
tolerating an 11-year old dress
step and drag dancing on a bar while
adult men throw dollar bills that's not
something we should tolerate there's
nothing good about that there's nothing
compassionate about tolerating that
what's really bizarre
well they're many bizarre aspects to
this story but what's especially bizarre
is the democrat treatment of sex because
because it's it's calling into light
this is essential lie at the center of
the left-wing treatment of sex which is
that we should affirm exotic sexuality
at all times at all ages
not just the thirty-five year old gay
guy who lives in the village
not just the adult drag queen but for
teenagers for young teenagers for
children we you know Owen Benjamin the
conservative comedian was kicked off of
social media because he said that
parents should not be allowed to shoot
their toddlers full of hormones to make
them resemble the opposite sex he said
it's a bad idea to castrate your
children and he was booted off of social
media for being a hater but that's what
it's come to now we're now they talk
about how at all stages now including a
ten-year-old 11 year old kid who is
being totally exploited by his horrific
parents that and you know he's got a
website up and he's going on television
we should totally affirm all of this
provocative bizarre sexual behavior but
then on the other hand the left tells us
that the most important thing in the
world is consent nothing everything
about sex is fine except it has to be
consensual it has to be so consensual
that every single step of the way you
need to sign a written form that says I
consent to do this I can be kissed I can
be touched I can be hugged I can do this
I can do that so we're so focused on
consent that baby it's cold outside is
being banned from radio stations because
they think that the song will one
because they completely misunderstand
what that song is about but because that
they think that the literal words in a
couple of the verses imply that there
isn't 100% consent they say it's all
about consent that's the main aspect of
sexual relations between people and also
young children should be able to explore
whatever sexuality they want
young children are not capable of giving
consent this is why we have statutory
rape laws this is why your where we have
the age of consent now is the age of
consent 17 or 18 or 16 depending on the
state maybe I don't know can you give
consent when you're 15 I don't know
maybe you can you certainly can't give
consent when you're 11 we know that
that's the case but and the left is
caught up in this because they want to
affirm they want to make an idol out of
sexual bizarreness they want to make an
idol out of exotic sexual behaviors but
they also have made an idol out of
consent clinical consent the two can't
go together they're totally in conflict
and they're in conflict on this
transgender issue just as much as
transgenderism and feminism are in
conflict this is the this is one of the
most enjoyable parts in a sort of shot
in Freud a way of looking at the left
right now is the left by embracing
intersectionality the idea that all of
these disparate groups who might
disagree with each other or have
different interests but they can band
together to oppose the straight white
male who thinks that he's a male because
of intersectionality you have the
feminists and the transgender estate up
together but they make opposite claims
on the one hand feminism talks about
women as women women as different from
men women as having different interests
than men women as having as having been
oppressed by men over time and then the
transgender astrology says oh there's
really no such thing as women and men
men can be women women can be men
there's no such thing as an innate
sexual difference or a fundamental
sexual difference at all this came out
most hilariously in the Miss Universe
pageant over the weekend in Miss
Universe a man almost became the Miss
Universe I I would love if I could be a
fly on the wall of feminists now we're
so confused say oh this is great because
we're affirming sexual as well but it's
a man but in a man in a bikini and
that's a good women in bikinis or bad
men in bikinis are good ID here is a
little bit of the coverage of Miss
Universe and we are back now with that
groundbreaking night at the Miss
Universe pageant Miss
spaying making history just by being
there and Miss Philippines winning the
crown lares got all the details
good morning good morning to you all yes
it was quite a night lots of pomp and
pageantry a few stumbles along the way
as well but it was also a night at first
the first all-female judging panel as
well as the first transgender contestant
overnight history made at Miss Universe
Spanish model Angela Ponte becoming the
first transgender woman to compete in
the 66 year old pageant the audience
greeting her with a standing of that is
groundbreaking that is definitely a
groundbreaking thing for a dude to
become Miss Universe it is it's great at
the very least it's groundbreaking it's
completely illogical but it's
groundbreaking the other aspect of this
story that no one is covering is that
Donald Trump used to run Miss Universe
and when Trump ran Miss Universe this
was a theme of the 2016 campaign the
left tells us that was really bad oh it
was so bad Miss Universe is so bad
it objectifies women it exploits women
it has it makes women that pig that pig
misogynist Donald Trump makes women trot
out onto the stage wearing bikinis for
our sexual pleasure that's so terrible
unless a man does it and then it's
beautiful
unless the Trump doesn't run it anymore
and then a man wears a bikini and then
that's good I are we to conclude from
that that it's perfectly fine to
sexually objectify men who think that
they're women but it's very wrong to
sexually objectify women I thought trans
women are women what is it's very very
confusing good luck trying to wrap your
head around that what this shows you is
this underlying this underlying fact of
the left which is they don't really have
a problem with the bikinis they don't
really have a problem with beauty
contests what they really have a problem
with is Donald Trump what they really
have a problem with is men what they
really have a problem with is the
patriarchy what they really have a
problem with is Western civilization
that's what they don't like that's
they hate they hate norms and they hate
traditions I mean the bizarre story of
an exploiting an eleven-year-old to do a
sex act or a sex sexual dance for adult
men throwing dollar bills at him
that is obviously awful and offends
every person of right reason but the
reason that the left will embrace that
sort of thing is because it subverts our
traditional culture it subverts the
mores of our society it subverts our
civilization and the same thing is true
of this transgenderism pageant the left
doesn't care about not certainly they
don't care about the child sexual abuse
per se that that drag queen kid tells
you everything about that they don't
care about the alleged misogyny of these
beauty pageants they don't really care
what they care about is undoing
tradition under I mean the fact that
Donald Trump ran this thing was the is
the greatest demonstration of this at
all they hate that they they it's it's a
sort of like I don't like you dad I'm
really angry at you dad and I'm it's a
it's a cultural rebellion because they
the Miss Universe didn't change last
year to this year two years ago to this
year nothing about it changed except
this time it was a dude wearing the
bikini and the dude wearing the bikini
is bizarre because he's not Miss
Universe he can't be Miss Universe he's
got it I guess he could be mr. universe
even though he looks a little bit more
like a Miss Universe that's what they're
after they're after uh uh pending our
society they're after getting us all
riled up and getting us angry it's a
it's a silly rebellion it's a frivolous
rebellion but it really shows the the
nihilism of the left it shows that
they're not really after anything you
can't think of a unifying message right
now among Democrats are on the Left
they're not they don't have a proactive
program I'm not saying we should do this
we need to do this we need to it's just
I hate Trump i f Trump F this resist
resist break down smash the patriarchy
this that and the other thing we see
this explicitly by the way on some of
the other social issues on abortion on
euthanasia we the left is just has just
a negative agenda at this point it's an
inverted backwards agenda and
there's there's no way clearer than
watching a man strut down a stage in a
bikini we have got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube if you were on the
daily wire.com thank you very much we
appreciate it keeps the lights on it
keeps coffe fa in my cup if you are not
go to daily wire.com right now what do
you get it's ten bucks a month $100 for
an annual membership you get me you get
the underemployment or you get the Ben
Shapiro show you test questions in the
mailbag that's coming up on Thursday you
get to ask questions in the conversation
and tomorrow at 5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30
p.m. Pacific Ben Shapiro will be taking
all of your questions and blowing your
mind with all of his wisdom live on the
air
did Ben write that then put that in
there I think I don't remember writing
that in least your crests will be there
to collect all of the leftist tears so
that the great flood doesn't happen
again
Wow that'll be a lot of fun what else
you get a lot of other stuff too you get
to ask questions in backstage you get
another Kingdom which is getting great
ratings huge ratings too killing it in
the ratings folks so go over there you
got a ton of stuff but this is what you
really get you get the leftist here's
tumblr because I'm dreaming of a white
Christmas on Christmas Day when the
federal government is shut down so that
we can get Santa Claus to bring us a
five billion dollar border wall that's
ten feet higher you're gonna have those
leftist tears free is in the atmosphere
and they're gonna create beautiful
fluffy snowflakes and you'll need your
leftist ears tumblr or you will be
crushed in the avalanche go to daily
wire calm we'll be right back with a lot
more
I have long said that the left's agenda
is an agenda of destruction there it's
not a constructive agenda it's not about
building something new it's about
tearing down everything that we have in
our society and our in our families and
our civilization this became explicit
this actually surprised me today in the
New York Times they ran an op-ed about
how human extinction would be a good
thing true story
clemson professor this was written by an
academic somebody teaching your children
his name is Todd May of course his name
is Todd of what you know of course a guy
like Todd would talk about how we have
to exterminate the humans so that the
delta smelt can swim a little easier
it's a total Todd move the the headline
is would human extinction be a tragedy
and you won't believe the answer the
sub-header says our species possesses
inherent value but we are devastating
the earth and causing unimaginable
animal suffering so Todd you know which
side Todd comes down on he says the
human extinction would not be a tragedy
this is just the first paragraph or so
he said Todd Todd writes let me start
with a claim that I think will be at
once depressing and upon reflection on
controversial human beings are
destroying large parts of the
inhabitable earth and causing
unimaginable suffering to many of the
animals that inhabit it this is
happening for at least three means first
human contribution to climate change is
devastating ecosystems as the recent
article on Yellowstone Park in The Times
exemplifies second increasing human
population is encroaching on ecosystems
that would otherwise be intact third
factory farming fosters the creation of
millions upon millions of animals for
whom it offers nothing but suffering and
misery before slaughtering them in often
barbaric ways mmm delicious
there is no reason to think that those
practices are going to diminish anytime
soon
quite the opposite humanity then is the
source of devastation of the lives of
conscious animals on a scale that is
difficult to comprehend I wish I could
get been in here to play the violin
while my finger
rub together one to the other it's so
wet so it's not difficult to comprehend
at all but this what is difficult for a
lot of people even for conservatives to
comprehend is this recurring theme of
leftism which is to discourage life and
hasten death you see it an abortion
killing incipient human life you see it
in the redefinition of marriage trying
to break down the building block of
society and discourage procreation you
see this in a euthanasia the left is so
happy giddy to kill people who are
suffering in some way or who are old and
deemed unuseful to society and now you
see this in a call for the mass
extinction of the human race they don't
love the environment they hate humans
that's what this is about they don't
really care about the delta smelt they
don't care about the little baby cow who
makes the delicious veal they they hate
humans that's what it's about they don't
care about child abuse they they want to
undermine our basic civil and cultural
institutions that sometimes interact
with that they that this is what it's
all about it's a negative agenda and we
should identify that source it's really
bizarre it's really we like to think
that we're just having two rational
political conversations well I want this
policy well I want this policy well I
want to pay a little more in taxes I
want to pay a little less in taxes but
there is a philosophical and a spiritual
basis to these two visions of the world
and the philosophical and spiritual
basis of the left is perverse and really
awful it is anti life it is anti
flourishing it is anti production you
know the I I hate to make it too I don't
want to seem hyperbolic in discussing
the spirituality of this but evil does
have a persona it has a personality I'm
not saying that leftists are evil I'm
not saying leftists are consciously evil
but they are indulging in ideas which
are ultimately wicked which are
ultimately nihilistic which says that
the delta smelt exists so that I may
serve the
to smelt that isn't true we love animals
we want to protect animals we want to
protect them so that we can enjoy them
and they're beautiful and we like to
look at them and ultimately we want to
serve them to each other on dinner
plates that is what it's for we do not
exist to be the slaves of the natural
environment the natural environment is
there for us to enjoy there also by the
way only loosely related there is a
groundbreaking study that came out today
you might have seen it came out from
Amnesty International
it showed that Twitter is a mean place I
know well I should have warned you I
should have said pull over your car
before you hear this turns out Twitter
is mean Amnesty International this big
wide-ranging survey showed the Twitter
is quote a toxic place quote the world's
biggest data set of online abuse
targeting women online abuse especially
toward women the thing is there's no
actual abuse on Twitter because there
can't be any abuse on Twitter what is
abuse the word abuse actually means to
misuse to use something in a way that's
not intended for so you can't you can
emotionally abuse people you certainly
can do that you can emotionally abuse
family members at the dinner table you
can do that there isn't abuse on Twitter
because Twitter is a place that exists
to incentivize abuse it's a place where
you say really mean things and you do it
but usually from an anonymous account so
you don't have to show who you are and
your direct you to people that you don't
know that you're not really interacting
with in a personal way what the left
really means is that Twitter inspires
violence that's what they're really
saying they're saying it's a place of
violence against women they're trying to
conflate abuse and speech with violence
and this is what they always do they can
flayed speech with violence so that they
can go after us and censor us this study
used the quote troll patrol of 6,500
volunteers they analyzed millions of
tweets milena Marin the senior advisor
for tactical research at Amnesty
International said in a statement
Twitter's failure to crack down on this
problem means it is contributing to the
silencing of already marginalized voices
okay here they're using the word
silencing to mean not silencing what are
they saying Twitter's failure to censor
people who say mean things
and who defines what's mean who defines
what's abuse twitter does who is it is
it abuse to say that men are not women
because there was a major feminist
writer who just lost her entire Twitter
account for saying that men are not
women is that abuse yeah of course
twitter defines that as abuse so what
they're saying is Twitter's failure to
censor these people means it is
contributing to the silencing of
marginalized voices who's silencing
anybody if you say something mean to
somebody or you were really more likely
you say something disagreeable to
somebody you aren't silencing them
you're saying something and then they
can say something to you or they cannot
say something to you
or they can say something to somebody
else at no point are you silencing
anybody it is such Orwellian language
that Amnesty International is using they
are using silencing to mean the opposite
of silencing and there you and they're
using that threat to say that we should
really silence other people they refer
to marginalized voices who are the
marginalized voices is Jake Tapper a
marginalized voice are they or no I
don't think so I think that people are
they're not marginal the people who are
marginalized are the ones who are being
threatened with censorship or who are
being threatened it is it is true
Twitter is contributing to marginalizing
many voices in in the country the
trouble is what they're marginalizing
are conservative voices all right that's
our show that's the whole thing we got
to get out of here I know we run late we
always run late tune back in I know I
was on the road yesterday I'm gonna be
on the road later this week too by the
way I'm gonna be taking a trip down to
Palm Beach I don't know why I don't know
if it's been announced why I'm doing
that but I'll just be going down to Palm
Beach what's in Palm Beach I don't know
we're gonna be having a good time down
there but I'll keep you posted on when
that is in the meantime I'll be back
here just in the same seat tomorrow I
will see you then I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018